and finally new rule Democratic
candidates have to stop telling me who
they will not take money from money from
bad people I don't care if they're bad I
just want to know if their money is good
Democrats always living in the world
that ought to be rather than the one
that is my campaign is funded by the
people well great but I got some bad
news for you the people are broke Bernie
Sanders does the best among Democrats
raising 46 million in February but in
the same period the Republicans raised
86 million some of it from Americans
[Applause]
because Trump will take money from
anyone super PACs corporate lobbyists
drug dealers Russian mobsters foreign
dictators he will and has stolen money
from his own charities meanwhile
Democrats are competing to see not who
can attract the most donors but to see
who can refuse the most because their
pure pure losers Bernie Sanders brags
that he accepts no money from corporate
PACs super PACs fossil fuels insurance
drug companies no siree if you want to
give Sanders money you had better be
able to prove you don't have any
Elizabeth Warren once boasted that a
college student came up to her and said
they had a total of six dollars to their
name but wanted to give Warren three and
she took it
she took half from a person who had six
dollars
this isn't pure tea it's vanity its
unilateral disarmament it's bringing a
hug to a gunfight in 2008 nobody took
more money from Wall Street than Obama
and then he got elected and passed the
biggest Wall Street Reform in
generations
he made Elizabeth Warren's plan the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau a
reality so when he ran for re-election
Wall Street was best and did not give
him nearly as much but he took what they
gave and then he [ __ ] them again
this is how you played the game call him
impure a corporatist of moderate fact is
he did more to rein in Wall Street than
all the peacocking comment board
socialists combined and I don't care
which old white guy we wheel into the
Oval Office
[Applause]
if Trump can take money from criminals
and foreign governments you can take it
from Aetna and here's a little secret
about economics when you take money from
bad people it's money that they the bad
people don't have it's not a donation at
all it's a fine but Democrats they don't
just reject money they return it Warren
and Cory Booker gave back their
donations from Harvey Weinstein why the
money didn't rape anybody because it's
money it doesn't know where it came from
[ __ ] sake it's money not Cal Bernie
loves to say my average donation is $18
but that's also a donor class half the
adults in this country live around the
poverty level they can't afford to be
part of this feel-good grassroots
fundraising system so none of it is pure
the only fair solution is complete
public financing of campaigns but in
but until that happens get off your high
horse about wine caves and billionaires
who want to help purists keep saying you
can't buy an election I say against
Trump please do
not to sound like a trophy wife but Mike
Bloomberg's money is very attractive to
me
he's promised to spend billions on
whoever is the Democratic nominee that's
a really good offer even if you hate him
think of it as a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to watch the world's ninth
richest man spend a fortune to elect a
socialism oh but but wait Bernie says if
he's the nominee he's not taking a dime
from Bloomberg really really in an
election we have all agreed is
existential you couldn't use a billion
dollar war chest
Bloomberg's money wasn't dirty when it
was changing gun politics or getting
tons of women elected or taking on
climate change he spent 40 million on 24
House races in 2018 and the Democrats
won 21 of them so maybe stop badgering
the guy every five minutes because he
told a [ __ ] joke in nineteen
be nice he's paying or offering to for
the election let'em just so I don't have
to see any more of these mass text
messages from candidates acting like
they know me hey Belle get the [ __ ] out
of here you don't know me like that I
got one from fighting the other day that
just said hey you up
[Laughter]
so you say some of the people donated to
Democrats are bad I say here's how we
know they're good because they're giving
you money to beat this guy
[Applause]
you